[Musique]
bonjour Marie Lise Léon merci beaucoup
on est ravi de vous accueillir pour la
première fois sur ce plateau vous êtes
secrétaire général de la CFDT on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par Stéphane Vernet
de Ouest France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour on va parler de la actualité
d'une autre actualité puisque
l'assemblée entame aujourd'hui l'examen
du budget de la Sécurité sociale parmi
les mesures possibles la mise à
contribution de l'agir Carco c'est la
caisse de retraite du privé pour
participer à l'équilibre du régime de
retraite vous y êtes opposé vous et les
partenaires sociaux pour le moment la
mesure ne figure pas dans le texte
est-ce que vous avez l'espoir que le
gouvernement y renonce absolument oui
oui je pense qu'on a su fait on a fait
preuve de de de responsabilité
organisation syndicale et patronale on a
conclu un accord avec du plus plus pour
les retraités 13 millions de retraités
qui bénéficient de la retraite
complémentaire une revalorisation à
hauteur de 4,9 % de la de la pension la
fin d'un malus le la question de la
possibilité d'avoir du cumul emploi
retraite enfin voilà ça fait partie de
la de la c'éit ça faisait partie de la
donne de départ de cette négociation on
a rempli on a voilà dire vous êtes sûr
que le gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur
cette mesure alors ça ça fait partie des
des inconnus voilà donc on a eu le temps
de de discuter aussi avec le
gouvernement après la conclusion de
l'accord et donc on a expliqué aussi en
quoi on était opposé à cette à cette
ponction euh donc on attend voilà la
décision mais vous attendez qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que vous faites si parce que
le gouvernement par voie d'amendement
peut encore inoduire cette tontion
quelle sera votre réaction si c'est le
cas bah on réagira on verra je pense que
déjà il faudra qu'on qu'on se coordonne
entre signataire de l'accord puisque ça
fait l'objet des discussions pendant la
négociation au au global on avait une
nous ouvert un peu la porte en disant
bon s'il doit y avoir soutien du régime
complémentaire à la mesure notamment
pour le les basses pensions du régime
général on est prêt à regarder le
gouvernement a été intransigent on n'a
pas souhaité
euh regarder le montant avec nous donc
donc on en discutera entre entre
signataires de de quelle sera la
meilleure voilà la même la meilleure
position la meilleure stratégie ça sera
quand même un sacré contresal d'un
gouvernement qui nous explique depuis le
mois de juillet qu'il ch de méthodes qui
veulent du dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales et patronnales
et qui et qui
veulent que chacun prenne sa place et
ses responsabilités je pense qu'on a
pris notre place on est en
responsabilité avec cet accord donc ce
seraoque de respect pour vous ça serait
ça serait ça serait juste du discours et
et là l'illustration par les actes que
l'on souhaite que le gouvernement ne
pratique pas cette fonction dans le
cadre du PLFSS mais Olivier DOP lui il
disait alors il disait on verra ce qu'il
en est que la réforme des retraites
génère un excédent de plus d'un milliard
et que donc il est légitime que cette
part puisse financer le régime est-ce
qu'il a pas raison alors il a pas raison
sur l'année 2000 2024 puisquon est dans
ça ça ça va être une mesure qui va
entrer en en puissance petit à petit et
puis là où je trouve que le gouvernement
est pas tout à fait cohérent c'est qu'il
nous explique que avec une mesure
paramétrique les bénéfices en tout cas
de cette mesure atterrisse dans le
régime complémentaire dans ce cas-là il
fallait mieux faire une un une réforme
globale systémique comme ça avait été le
cas en 2019 on avait commencé à discuter
de de cette de cette réforme donc je
vous sou qu' Revne sur la table cette
réformme systm je trouve que c'est pas
très cohérent et je je reste convaincu
et mon organisation la CFDT reste
convaincu que la meilleure des réformes
la plus équitable serait une réforme qui
remet à plat l'ensemble des régimes et
qu'on puisse just il faut une nouvelle
réforme des retraites pour vous vous
appelez une nouvelle réforme des retit
étaé clair sur le fait qu'une mesure
strictement paramétrique comme ça a été
le cas en début d'année est la plus
injuste notamment pour les personnes qui
qui ont des des petites des petits
revenus qui ont des qui sont exposés à
des critères de de pénibilité qui ont
commencé tôt à travailler voilà donc
mais à quelle échéance Durance quinquena
il faut sais pas je sa pas V sou je je
je ne sais pas quel sera euh nous on
souhaite qu'il puisse y avoir
effectivement qu'on continue de de de
discuter sur cette cet enjeu et cette
question de de d'un régime universel la
question de l'équité de la justice
sociale n'est absolument pas traitée
avec la réforme paramétrique de des 64
ans après moi j'ai beaucoup entendu des
députés notamment m'expliquer que grâce
à cette réforme on était tranquille pour
50 ans voilà donc je pense que c'est un
sujet qui nécessitera de toute façon je
ne sais pas à quelle échance d'être
d'être repris bon mais sur laag Carco
vous êtes optimiste je j'espère que le
gouvernement
j'espère qu'il sera en en cohérence avec
ce qui nous a été dit en mois de juillet
et moi j'attends après avoir eu ces
discours des actes concrets et qui nous
laissent bien gérer agir Carco comme
comme on a et c'est toujours une ligne
rouge pour vous et c'est une c'est une
ligne rouge oui on va parler d'un de la
loi plein emploi Stéphan oui autre sujet
de la semaine la commission mixte
paritaire entre scénat et assemblée est
parvenu à un accord en début de semaine
sur le projet de loi plein emploi est-ce
que le texte le compromis trouvé vous
vient-il alors on est euh on est on est
en en en désaccord avec un certain
nombre de points euh qui qui sont pas
nouveau c'est une loi sur le plein
emploi qui ne dit pas complètement son
nom en fait puisque c'est une réforme
profonde du RSA et qui
euh a une approche qui ne nous convient
pas c'est que nous sommes nous tout à
faait en accord avec cet cet objectif du
plein emploi la façon de d'y arriver
nous semble pas la bonne l'inscription
l'inscription des bénéficiaires du RSA
l'inscription automatique sur les liste
de demandeurs d'emploi par exemple ça
c'est une bte bah c'est c'est un
changement de statut extrêmement
important c'est-à-dire qu'on considère
que y compris les conjoints des des
bénéficiaires du RSA sont inscrits à à
Pôle Emploi demain France travaille si
là le le la réforme va va au bout euh
c'est un changement de logique
c'est-à-dire qu'on considère que
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont au RSA
sont euh destinées à euh chercher et
trouver un emploi or on sait que euh
nous c'est ce que l'on souhaite mais on
sait qu'il y a des personnes qui ont des
difficultés particulières en terme de
santé en terme de santé santé mentale
notamment en terme de logement en terme
de mobilité et que les choses sont pas
si simples que ça donc une loi plein
emploi un France travail deain qui est
vraiment dédié ouvert tourné vers les
plus les plus éloignés de l'emploi et
qui permet un accompagnement ok euh mais
des des des pardon des allocataires du
RSA à France travail qui vont avoir des
comptes à rendre en terme de d'heur de
travail
d'activité par queut sénateur on
15 oui je le regrette parce que parce
que parce que c'est supposé quand même
et et laisser cette petite musique
s'installer que les les allocataires du
RSA finalement se contentent de leur
situation or pour les rencontrer
régulièrement ça n'est absolument pas le
cas le texte par exemple évoque des des
sanctions sous forme de suppression
mobilisation ça veut dire quoi bah ça ça
fait partie des sujets qu'on a posé des
questions qu'on a posé où on a pas eu
franchement et moi-même je ne sais pas
puisque et et moi la question c'est que
une suspension du RSA peut avoir des
conséquences absolument dramatiques pour
des personnes qui et là on parle on
parle de personnes qui de façon
individuelle touche 607 € par mois
c'est-à-dire que ce sont pas non plus
des personnes qui sont dans un un
contexte de et un cadre de vie qui est
euh qui est luxuriant donc on na pas
forcément les réponses surtout du alors
on nous explique que c'est pour
mobiliser mais que de c'est uniquement
pour maintenir le lien et cetera nous on
a porté des des éléments notamment sur
la remobilisation des des demandeurs
d'emploi par poôulemploi mais jamais il
n'a été question de suspendre ces
allocations alors il est question dans
France travail aussi d'avoir quatre
niveaux de gouvernance national régional
départemental local le tout orchestré
par Pôle Emploi est-ce que que ça peut
marcher un truc pareil en fait je pense
que je pense que ça peut marcher si les
rôles et les missions de chaque à chaque
niveau sont clair ce qui est pas encore
complètement le cas mais je pense que
c'est important qu'on puisse nous on est
extrêmement attaché à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir un dialogue à l'échelle nationale
à l'échelle régionale et à l'échelle
locale c'est-à-dire que lorsque l'on
veut trouver des
solutions extrêmement sur mesure pour
pour des personnes personalité des
personnes pardon qui sont en recherche
d'emploi et qui ont une multitude de de
on peut avoir une multitude de cas de
figure c'est important justement d'avoir
cette échelle cette échelle locale donc
à voir après quels seront le partage des
des rôles et puis comment surtout je
pense que c'est important que tout ne se
décide pas à l'échelle nationale on a
commencé l'émission en parlant de la
ponction sur le le régime GIR Carco là
sur le cette histoire de loi plein
emploi le le gouvernement part du
principe que si on arrive va faire
baisser le le taux de chômage à 5 % le
l'assurance chômage il y aura beaucoup
moins de chômeurs donc l'assurance
chômage va faire des économies
considérables donc le gouvernement veut
ponctionner l'assurance chômage à
hauteur de de 10 milliards plus de 10
milliards en prenant dans dans ses
futurs excédents qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez sur le sur le sur le principe sur
les chiffres sur le principe on est on
est on a toujours nous défendu à la CFDT
l'idée que une l'assurance chômage
c'était un une allocation de bon niveau
pour pouvoir trouver un emploi et de un
accompagnement de qualité donc on a
toujours toujours été ouvert à ce que
notamment une partie des des excédents
lunédiques soi fléchés vers pôul emploi
demain France travaille pour pouré pour
améliorer l'accompagnement donc qu' ait
des moyens dédiés je trouve ça
important après comme vous l'avez pointé
la négociation qui qui a démarré sur
l'assurance chômage elle se fait à
partir d'une lettre de cadrage avec des
des des comment dire des perspective
économique qui nous semble extrêmement
optimiste donc les 10 milliards qui sont
évoqué je pense que on on en sera
loin donc la négociation elle va se
faire surtout nous dans un cadre qu'on
va définir entre organisation syndicale
et patronnal et
euh toutes les projections toutes les
projections nous nous nous sont sont
faites à partir de 4,5 5 % de chômage on
sait aujourd'hui que on y sera pas que
la conjoncture est pas du tout dans la
même dynamique voilà donc on va on va
dans le casre de la négociation déjà
nous nous nous fixer aussi un cadre un
cadre budgétaire et et puis nous l'idée
de la négociation c'est comment on
améliore les droits des demandeurs
d'emploi c'est ça notre objectif un
dernier mot sur l'accompagnement des des
des demandeurs d'emploi Emmanuel Macron
annoncé hier le recrutement de 1000
éducateurs sociaux et sportifs
supplémentaires pour coacher les jeunes
engagés dans un parcours d'insertion il
annoncé ça il annoncé ça hier l'objet
serait l'objectif serait d'avoir 1500
coachs d'ici 2027 qui serait capable
d'aider 100000 jeunes parents suivant ce
dispositif qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez c'est une bonne
initiative ou pas bah faut il faut que
ce soit pas de enfin ça peut être une
bonne initiative si si l'objectif de
d'accompagnement moi je suis pas très
fan du terme de coaching ça ça fait un
peu gadget enfin je je voilà la question
c'est l'accompagnement et
l'accompagnement vers quoi et pourquoi
donc il suffit pas de dire que la que
les personnes ont été accompagnées c'est
c'est qu'est-ce que comment ça se
traduit et comment on permet à
l'insertion dans un emploi un emploi de
qualité et un emploi durable c'est ça
l'objectif voilà dans 2 semaines les
sénateurs entameront l'examen du projet
de loi immigration parmi les mesures il
y a ce fameux article 3 sur les titres
de séjour qui seraient accordés à aux
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tension est-ce que vous soutenez cet
article 3 tel que rédigé actuellement
par le gouvernement alors on a on manque
encore d'information il y a pas mal
d'éléments qu'il faut clarifier nous on
était pas on n'est pas forcément
favorable à cette question de de
régularisation en fonction d'une liste
parce qu'on sait que tout dépend en plus
comment la liste est est définie euh on
a peur que ça fige un peu les les choses
et que il y ait des personnes qui sont
en
situation de travail qui qui sont dans
des critères qui respectent les critères
et qui ne sont pas qui n'obtiennent pas
de
papier de notre point de vue il y a pas
que la question des métiers en tenstion
c'est un peu une vision un peu
adéquationniste de l'immigration qu'on
ne partage pas néanmoins euh il faut
regarder quells sont comment d'un point
de vue pratique ça peut fonctionner et
surtout si c'est adopté quelles sont les
modalités de définition de C de ces de
ces listes et donc et que c'est puisse
qu'on puisse avoir une dynamique et de
de voir comment ça peut évoluer mais
est-ce que vous vous souhaitez à tout
prix que ça figure dans le texte cet
article 3 parce que c'est une ligne
rouge notamment avec les sénateurs les
républicains Gérald harmanin dans le
Journal du dimanche il parle de thème
pas centrale ce matin dans Le Télégramme
Bruno Le Maire dit que le projet de
laimmigration ça doit être la fermeté la
fermeté la fermeté est-ce que vous
craignez que le gouvernement enlève cet
article oui c'est un risque c'est un
risque et il y a des choses à faire du
point de vue de l'immigration par le
travail et la reconnaissance de toutes
ces personnes qui sont pour certaines
depuis des mois voire des années sur sur
le territoire qui travaillent et qui
n'ont qui vient dans la plus grande
précaritéver ilut il faut que ça puisse
être il faut que ça puisse être débattu
et que on puisse reconnaître ce droit à
être sur le sol français lorsqu'on
travaille d'être dans des conditions
digne digne de ce nom il est question
aussi de passer par une circulaire
est-ce que ça ce serait acceptable pour
vous bah tout dépend tout dépend de ce
qui est tout dépend de ce qui est dans
la circulaire il y a déjà aujourd'hui
beaucoup de choses qui sont déterminées
par ce qu'on appelle une la pardon la
circulaire Val qui qui qui pose un
certain nombre de critères qui sont
interprétés et utilisés de façon assez
discrétionnaire en fonction en fonction
des des préfectures je trouve que c'est
pas suffisant il faut il faut être plus
plus ambitieux vous vous dites
clairement tous les travailleurs
étrangers en situation irrégulière
doivent être
régularisés ceux qui respectent les
critères qui ont été définis par par la
loi et qui sont traduits dans dans cette
circulaire je pense que après la
question elle est aussi de de de d'avoir
des moyens pour leur permettre de de de
d'être d'avoir des dossiers traités plus
rapidement je pense qu'on a un enjeu en
France aujourd'hui pour toutes ces
personnes qui travaillent d'être
accueillies dignement et d'être
rapidement fixé sur la façon dont leur
dossier peut être traité ce qui ce qui
est humainement me semble la moindre des
choses Stéphane on reparle de la
conférence sociale sur les basses
salaires de la semaine la semaine
dernière vous vous disiez avant de vous
vous rendre que vous refusiez que ce
soit un rendez-vous pour rien ça un
petit peu ressemblé à ça quand même non
non je avec le recul vous êtes moins
déçu qu'au départ euh alors on on a
toujours dit que c'était un rendez-vous
utile puisquil permet d'ouvrir un
certain nombre de de de sujet euh qui
est un peu timide un rendez-vous un peu
timide parce qu'en terme de de sortie il
y a pas d'élément extrêmement concret
alors vous demandz notamment le le le la
suppression de des exonérations de
cotisation pour les entreprises qui
jouent pas le jeu ça a été évoquer mais
avec une espèce de clause de revoyure
pour l'été 2024 c'est très loin quand
même non c'est ce que c'est ce que je
pourrais qualifier de timide néanmoins
symboliquement c'est extrêmement
important ça va exactement dans le sens
qu'on qu'on souhaitait parce qu'en fait
on est nous les fervants défenseurs de
du d'une négociation collective
dynamique dans les entreprise dans les
branches professionnelles nous on
proposait que les branches qui ne jouent
pas le jeu elles ne puissent plus
bénéficier de certaines exonérations de
cotisation là le gouvernement il ouvre
quand même franchement la porte en
disant on va pas le faire tout de suite
mais et on va pas supprimer mais on va
diminuer certaines exos je pense que
c'est important symboliquement ça fait
des années que la
C et puis euh et puis de de de dynamiser
la négociation quand la no fonctionne ce
qu'on a fait récemment dans le secteur
de la prévention et sécurité on a eu des
avancées extrêmement concrètes sur 3 ans
d'un engagement de revalorisation
salariale il y a des branches qui jouent
pas le jeu comme par exemple la branche
des des agents agents d'accueil ou ou
plateforme téléphonique c'est 182000
salariés qui sont concernés la no elle
est en panne bah il faut qu'il puisse y
avoir une intervention de l'État dans
ces cas-là donc ça c'est une façon de de
rel lancer la négociation le Haut
Conseil des
rémunération pardon je recommence le
Haut Conseil des
rémunération c'est c'est bien ou c'est
juste un machin en plus non c'est bien
bah tout dépend ce qu'on met dedans
c'est là que il faut aller au encore
beaucoup d'interrogations quand même il
y a encore beaucoup
d'interrogation mais voilà donc c'est
non je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans
mais je sais ce que la CFDT veut déjà et
nous on est pour déjà pas mal supprimer
le comité des expertsmic qui fait des
constats et on avait nous proposé
commission bas salaire de regarder qui
sont les salariés qui ont des bas
salaires qui sont proches du SMIC qui
ont des mauvaises conditions de travail
pas de perspective d'évolution de
carrière et qu'il puisse y avoir une
commission qui travaille sur
l'observation de de ces situation et qui
fasse des propositions nous on veut pas
un comité Théodule qui fasse le constat
que les choses vont mal on veut un un un
comité ou une commission ce que vous
voulez qui fasse des constats et qui
fasse des propositions pour faire
évoluer ces situations alors justement
il y a y a il y a la question parmi les
bas salaires et cetera les problèmes de
d'égalité salariale il y a la question
de l'égalité salariale femme homme ça
c'est un de vos grands combats c'est un
sujet sur lequel on avance toujours pas
ou mal revoir l'index qui existe est-ce
que c'est une bonne chose ou est-ce
qu'il est pas il serait pas temp en fait
de de trouver un moyen de faire
appliquer la loi par exemple en la
matière l'arsenal législatif est plus
que fourni sur ce qui concerne l'égalité
homm femmes je pense que le problème de
l'index tel qu'il a été conçu c'est que
les DRH se sont dit je vais d'abord
avoir pour objectif avoir une bonne note
plutôt que de regarder comment je peux
faire évoluer et diminuer les écarts
salariaux entre les hommes et les femmes
là on est pas dans une révision ce qu'a
proposé le gouvernement c'est une
refonte donc nous on va regarder
effectivement en plus il y a une un
enjeu de transposition d'une directive
européenne sur la transparence je pense
que l'un des premiers obstacles à cette
réduction des écarts c'est que ça reste
encore extrêmement tabou et qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de salariés qui ne n'ont
pas conscience qu'il y a cet écart entre
le gouvernement jusqu'à à 2026 pour
transposer cette dispositive euren
est-ce que vous dites il faut accélérer
il faut qu'elle soit transposée dès
début 2024 il faut qu'elle le soit le
plus vite possible donc on va combiner
index et transposition de cette
directive il faut que ça puisse
allerectiv le plus vite possible alors
on va on a on a commencé on va avoir des
concertations cette semaine notamment
sur un sujet très complémentaire qui va
permettre de de d'avancer de réduire ses
écarts sur la question de la du partage
de la parentalité puisqu'on sait que les
femmes quand elles ont quand elles n'ont
pas d'enfant l'écart de salaire avec les
hommes est de l'ordre de 7 % lorsque
vous avez 3 enfants vous atteignez 31 %
donc il y a un enjeu de de partage de la
parentalité les concertations vont
démarrer cette semaine voilà donc aller
le plus vite possible c'est pas du côté
de la CFDT que il y aura les freins bien
entendu Stéphane vous avez une dernière
question sur Sophie
Binet oui dans dans l'interview croisée
que vous aviez donné à la tribune
dimanche avec Sophie Binet vous disiez
ne pas vouloir revenir au train train
syndical d'avant je vous cite après
l'élan du premier semestre ça veut dire
quoi comment on fait pour pour empêcher
le soufflet de retomberé notamment quand
on voit que la la la la journée de de
mobilisation du 13 octobre a pas
formidablement bien marché ben je dirais
le train train syndical c'est pas
uniquement rendez-vous avec vos baskets
dans la rue en manif hein tout ce dont
on a parlé jusqu'à maintenant c'est de
l'action syndicale extrêmement concrète
il y AE vitalité on voit ensemble un
c'est pas parce qu'on défile qu'on
défile moins régulièrement ensemble
qu'on ne se parle pas bien entendu qu'on
continue d'avoir des échanges avec J
Carco encore encore hier sur la question
de la négociation assurance chômage donc
la l'action syndicale peut pas être
résumé à ces à ces à cette cette à ce
défilé dans la rue ça a été extrêmement
important je pense que il faut souligner
que c'était une mobilisation
historique et donc voilà l'action se se
poursuit et l'action au quotidien dans
les entreprises elle se elle se poursuit
y compris par par la greffe par des
mobilisations je vais d'ailleurs cet
après-midi auprès des salariés de
Carrefour qui ont appris qu'ils allaient
passer de changer de statut leur magasin
allit passer en location gérance
clairement c'est une une atteinte
extrêmement importante à leur droit à la
diminution de leur rémunération parce
que voilà on a un groupe qui découpe
l'ensemble de son réseau de magasin en
petits morceau pour que ça lu co moins
cher et c'est purement scandaleux merci
marieiseon merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin Stéphan lae de
West France c'est Emmanuel Macron ce que
le chef d'État entend dire en Israël
c'est à la de votre journal merci
Stéphane à la semaine prochaine on passe
tout suite au club des territoires